los autos a b y c viajan a velocidades
constantes elige el auto que viaja más
rápido tenemos estas tres opciones los
invito a que pause en el vídeo y traten
de encontrar cuál auto viaja más rápido
el auto a el auto ve o el auto se
resolvamos estos juntos la opción dice
el auto viaja a 50 kilómetros por hora
la opción b dice el auto ve recorre una
distancia de 10 kilómetros en h horas
con base en la ecuación 55 h igual a d
veamos si podemos traducir esta ecuación
a kilómetros por hora vamos a reescribir
esta ecuación de es igual a 55 h
recuerden que estamos analizando el
escenario b no la opción a una forma de
comenzar con esto es dividir ambos lados
de la ecuación entre h para tener la
distancia entre el tiempo de entre h es
igual a 55 lo único que hicimos fue
dividir ambos lados entre h
nos dicen que de esta en km y h está en
horas por lo que las unidades
y son kilómetros por hora así que el
auto ve viaja a 55 kilómetros por hora
mientras que el auto a viaja a 50
kilómetros por hora nos dicen que el
auto se recorre 135 kilómetros en tres
horas vamos a encontrar la proporción
por hora de esta rapidez o la proporción
de unidades 135 kilómetros divididos
entre 3 horas 3 divide a 135 el 3 cabe
cuatro veces en el 13
13 - 12 da 1 bajamos el 5 y 3 cabe 5
veces en el 15 15 menos 15 es 0 no sobra
nada así que esto es igual a 45
kilómetros por hora el auto a viaja a 50
kilómetros por hora el auto ve viaja a
55 kilómetros por hora y el auto se
viaja a 45 kilómetros por hora el auto
que viaja más rápido es el auto ve
hagamos otro ejercicio cuáles relaciones
tienen la misma constante de
proporcionalidad entre iu y x como en la
ecuación 3 y igual a 27
aquí tenemos varias opciones que no
podemos ver por completo en la pantalla
pero para las tres opciones que pueden
ver pausa en el vídeo y traten de
encontrar cuáles de estas opciones
tienen la misma constante de
proporcionalidad que 3 igual a 27 x
resolvamos esto juntos primero tenemos
que encontrar la constante de
proporcionalidad de esta ecuación 3g
igual a 27 x una forma de encontrar la
constante de proporcionalidad es dejar
esta fórmula con el formato igual a r
por x donde r es la constante de
proporcionalidad
vamos a hacerlo para dejar esta ecuación
en este formato vamos a dividir a ambos
lados entre 3 y nos queda que igual a 27
entre 3 es 9 es igual a 9 x la constante
de proporcionalidad que buscamos es 9
esto es igual a la opción a la constante
de proporcionalidad es 9 marcamos ésta
como una respuesta correcta la opción b
dice 2 es igual a 18 x
dejamos de esta ecuación dividimos ambos
lados entre 2 nos queda igual a 9 x así
que esta también es una opción correcta
veamos la gráfica de la opción c cuando
x es igual a 1 y es igual a 9 otra forma
de verlo es que ya es 9 x x noten que
este punto es 19 y podemos ver que ya es
9 veces x nuevamente encontramos que la
constante de proporcionalidad es 9 las
tres opciones que podemos ver en
pantalla son correctas y vemos que nos
piden elegir tres respuestas así que
estas eran nuestras tres respuestas
vamos a verificar que las opciones que
no alcanzamos a ver no tienen una
constante de proporcionalidad igual a 9
en la opción de hay una tabla con la
relación entre x y jet para pasar de 3 a
un tercio porque número tenemos que
multiplicar tenemos que multiplicar por
1 entre 9 para pasar de 6 a 2 tercios
también tenemos que multiplicar por 1
entre 9 así que la constante de
proporcionalidad aquí es 1 entre 9 10
a 1 / 9 por equis en la opción para
pasar de 2 a 18 tenemos que multiplicar
el 2 por 9 esto es interesante para
pasar de 4 a 27 tenemos que multiplicar
el 4 por algo diferente a 9 y para pasar
de 6 a 36 tenemos que multiplicar por 6
así que aquí no existe una relación
proporcional entre xy mucho menos
tenemos una constante de
proporcionalidad con esto terminamos